a couple of women will be smiling once  again thanks to a local program  mothers emily bach and tanya brock were  chosen  out of more than 300 applicants to  receive a free  smile makeover from canyon oral and  facial surgery  now the organizers surprised them today  they spoke to us right after that  announcement  they tell us that they work multiple  jobs to care for their kids but  couldn't afford dental insurance and  really struggled with  her smile for years when she saw the  opportunity to apply on social media  she took a chance i never thought  in a million years that i would ever  i struggled for about a month before i  actually filled out the application  because i just wasn't sure if i could do  it  or if i'd be picked and i didn't want to  be disappointed  well emily was chosen along with tonya  to receive a complete smile treatment  including dental implants  she says this is going to do really  wonders for her self-confidence and she  is so  grateful